in America there's a new trend called
cancel culture basically somebody does
something offensive and they're finished
the latest example is a movie called the
hunt oddly this time it was
conservatives that took issue with it
they're only getting worse goes for
Hollywood to look at this Universal
Pictures set to release a brand-new
movie about hunting yes irredeemable
deplorable z' for sport hollywood is
racing what they're doing with the kind
of movies they're putting out it's
actually very dangerous for our country
but why is it acceptable to kill your
political adversaries whether right or
left
isn't that normalizing political murder
homicide so the movie was originally
called red state vs. blue state he had
elite wealthy liberals hunting down
average american working-class
conservatives for sport sounds like a
horror film
if you don't find it funny they're not
human beings every year a bunch of
elites kidnapped normal folk like us and
hunt us for sport
hurry hurry hurry up you take a closer
look at the movie it's pretty clear who
the heroes are and it's not those
liberal elites gunning down fine people
living in rural states the movie comes
across is rather pro-trump lampooning
the elite liberals without good
wholesome American values it almost
seems like conservatives were a bit too
quick to jump on the cancel it train but
at least cancel culture is diverse
conservatives won the battle with the
hunt it has been shell but now liberals
are up in arms about a film that they
say offends their values Adam that
portrays a teenager who becomes
transgender in the hopes of dating a
lesbian Adam is still in high school got
a girlfriend and I don't have one I'd
like one would you get your tough day
now critics have said that the movie is
actually a conversation starter when it
comes to the transgender issue however
it is unacceptable to transgender
activists hashtags are now calling for a
boycott this is deeply transphobic and
lesbian phobic it implies identities are
just costumes the film has been named
one of the most exciting LGBTQ films of
the year but if young people go and see
this it could be very damaging to them
Americans seem quite determined to ban
films that they consider to be offensive
however what about when the shoe is on
the other foot for example a few years
ago Hollywood cranked out a film called
the interview it portrayed the death of
Kim jong-un North Korea was outraged and
Sony's server got hacked now the US
media establishment was burning with
outrage why can't those Korean
communists take a joke why can't we
portray their leader being assassinated
free expression Sony's a corporation it
suffered significant damage there were
threats against its employees I am
sympathetic to the concerns that they
faced having said all that yes I think
they made a mistake we decided to talk
to some New Yorkers and see how they
feel about canceled culture and its
impact on the film industry I don't
believe in censorship in general unless
it's super super offensive we have to be
so careful about how we refer to people
or say things and that's you know which
changed so much I think people don't
recognize what think what are offensive
to some people that has been offensive
for a long time but I also think we've
gone a little extreme in the callout
culture we have so many different people
here we all need to understand but we
shouldn't be afraid to speak it I think
that Trump has given people in America
permission to dig deep down and and
express like their their prejudices
their hatred I think that therefore we
have to be a little bit careful about
where we go with that now there's no
point in pretending that Hollywood is
not political the films produced in the
United States are circulated all over
the world and they bring with them
cultural and political messages that
reflect the views of the United States
but lately it seems like those who are
being offended by what they see on the
silver screen aren't people on the other
side of the planet it's Americans
themselves Kaleb Maupin RT New York
you